so today I'm going to talk about vitamin
k2 and some of the functions that go way
beyond just dealing with bone formation
we talked about vitamin k2 most people
associate that with making your bones
more solid and also removing the soft
tissue calcium from the joints or the
arteries and then driving that into the
bone and vitamin k2 works with item and
D but vitamin k2 does a lot more as far
as the function of bone goes we might
think it's just a structural scaffolding
to hold everything together but bone not
only provides a structural function but
it's vital in making immune cells a lot
of your immune cells originate from the
bone marrow but there's another
interesting function your bone acts as
an endocrine gland it makes a hormone
called osteocalcin has to do with a
hormone that can affect your blood
sugars and it just so happens that
vitamin k2 triggers this hormone so
vitamin k2 has the capacity of improving
insulin resistance and when I say
improving insulin resistance I'm not
talking about worsening insulin
resistance talking about making it
better because vitamin k2 can increase
insulin sensitivity and there's so many
people on this planet right now that
have a problem with instant resistance
without being aware of it so vitamin k2
can help stabilize your blood sugars and
increase the output the production of
insulin from your pancreas but it does
other things as well it has a capacity
to suppress inflammation vitamin k2 is
an anti-inflammatory vitamin we know
vitamin D is anti-inflammatory by
vitamin k2 can also help as well now
number four vitamin k2 can decrease fat
accumulation why because it helps to
balance insulin all right number five
vitamin k2 can also increase the
capacity of energy in your mitochondria
when you exercise now I have some
personal experience on this one
here when I take vitamin k2 30 minutes
before I go on a bike ride I have much
better endurance especially going up
hills now and number six
it can even increase testosterone now
realize if you're female it's not going
to increase testosterone beyond your
normal levels okay so it's just gonna
help balance testosterone now let's talk
about the foods that are high in vitamin
k2 NATO which is fermented soybeans
butter if it's grass-fed yolk as an egg
yolk goose liver
pepperoni of course without the nitrates
salami without the nitrates sausage
sauerkraut in certain cheese's like
Munster cheese Gouda brie another one
being Edom and hard cheese the key is
grass-fed chase now if you look at some
of these foods like NATO and sauerkraut
k2 is made by a bacteria it's part of
the fermentation process now if you look
at some of these other ones they're
either coming from an animal fat or milk
or an egg but the animal originally a
grass which has a lot of vitamin k1 and
then converts it to k2 as a fat soluble
vitamin and it gets stored in the fat
for more information about k2 check out
this video right here